- Okay, so before the board was digital,
did you ever turn the wrong letter around?
'Cause that would've kind
of ruined everything.
(Kelly laughs)
- One time I did it. I was mortified.
I don't even remember which
was the correct puzzle.
It was either "Dr. Spock" or "Mr. Spock",
and I turned the M or
the D and it was like,
(gasps), that's the
wrong letter, oh my gosh.
So I mean, I'm scarred for life on that.
- Wait what happened?
Did they have to like
throw that one out? Like...
- They did.
They had to throw it out
and put another one in.
- [In-Person Guest] Yeah,
but one time in 40 years?
- I know, I'm like, one time only?
- Fortunately,
in 1997,
they changed the puzzle board,
where I only touch the letters.
And when I touch them,
I won't touch them unless they light up.
So the mistake will not be mine.
- [In-Person Guest] Oh.
- Oh, I love that.
Yeah. There's someone else under that bus.
That's what I'd do.
So you're doing Celebrity
Wheel of Fortune now,
so are famous people better or worse
than your usual contestants?
Cause that was pretty funny.
It took a minute to get that L out. So.
(Kelly and In-Person Guest laugh)
- [On-Screen Guest]
They're definitely fun.
You know, they have a great time.
And I'm really surprised
at how good they really do!
- Oh my gosh. I think I would
be nervous under the pressure,
but girl, I love some Wheel
of Fortune slot machines.
- I would do it.
- Wait, you would do it?
- I'd try, but I would not do
well. Probably I'd be nervous.